the weinstein company's board of
directors is expected to meet today to
discuss the company's possible sale amid
the scandal surrounding ousted
co-founder Harvey Weinstein billionaire
financier Thomas Baraka close confidant
the president Trump has emerged as a
potential buyer more than 50 women now
accused Harvey Weinstein of sexual
harassment or assault bianna golodryga
shows us how those allegations cast
doubt on the company's future beyond a
good morning good morning a big day for
the company Harvey's brother Bob
Weinstein spent the weekend condemning
Harvey and insisting he wasn't going to
unload the company they built together
but it appears the other two remaining
board members have other ideas and are
desperately seeking a way out as the
number of Harvey Weinstein's accusers
grows the studio he founded is in
financial freefall The Weinstein Company
as it is has just become so toxic that
they can't continue business Ben Fritz
of the Wall Street Journal spoke to a
Weinstein Company official who estimates
the company could now be worth 300
million dollars last year Harvey
Weinstein estimated his company was
worth at least 700 million dollars due
to a powerhouse library that includes
the film's lion the imitation game and
the television hit Project Runway's time
is intercal any capital a private equity
firm offering a buyout that would save
The Weinstein Company it's probably
declining in value every day is
important more these accusations come
out board members have refused to say
what they knew about wine scenes decades
of alleged abusive behavior it was the
easy option just to turn a blind eye
behavior Ivana Lowell who dated Harvey's
brother Bob began writing about in 2010
that's Harvey and that's how he is and
that was how everyone in the office I
think felt people were very scared of
him and everyone was scared that they
could lose their job like any good
screenplay the weinstein company's
possible sale comes with a twist the man
at the helm of colony capital is Tom
barek I have only amazing things to tell
you about Donald a close ally of
President Trump can only imagine that
Tom beric and some of his friends have a
little glee at the idea that they are
buying at the studio that was run by
this very prominent Hillary Clinton
supporter
Harvey Weinstein continues to deny any
allegations of non-consensual sex he has
also had a previous business relation
with Berek Berek was one of the
investors who bought the Weinsteins
previous company Miramax from Disney and
2010 of course the big question does
remain what did the board know and win
all sorts of plot twists with this very
sad saga yeah watch it unfold
thank you bianna